boa tarde
mas também o fraco meio desanimado o
mais forte e boa tarde que vó tem aqui a
nossa bandeira vou colocar aqui junto
com as iminentes
eu sou audilene adiante
moro no município de cruzeiro do sul
sou casada tenho três filhos cinco netos
e faço parte da coordenação da escola de
jovens rurais da diocese de santa cruz
do sul que já temos 25 anos trabalho com
a juventude da roça
também faço parte da pastoral da terra
do rio grande do sul então o nosso
trabalho de que nós temos com a
juventude ea semente
eu trouxe algumas sementes aqui também
algumas frutas que perpassa junto a essa
formação
a nossa escola ela na escola que forma
jovens multiplicadores do projeto de
agroecologia na escola a juventude de 14
a 35 anos participa da formação ea
escola funciona organizada locais
sabinos nos municípios junto com com
indígenas quilombolas alemães e
italianos
os polacos que mobilizam causa que diz
vou lá com mas os poloneses e todas as é
pessoas por nossa da nossa região e no
nosso brasil e que ela funciona assim
ela ela tem o tempo integração que são
todos os jovens este ano nós temos 120
nas duas regiões da taquara e vale do
rio pardo não têm o tempo integração que
tudo junto a todos os jovens o tempo
como
a idade é quando você vai lá de que o
jovem mora perto dos seus pais junto com
professores com prefeitos ou emater
todos aqueles que querem realmente fazer
que a agroecologia acontece e tudo isso
que a gente vem fazendo é para proteger
a natureza
a nossa grande mãe terra proteger ela
produzindo alimento sem prejudicar
então a nós temos três grandes eixos na
escola ea gente forma o jovem na questão
da agrícola jia para conhecer a semente
quando lançar como fazer é a questão
também política que passa a operar essa
organização associativismo
cooperativismo e toda essas questões as
políticas públicas porque nós como
escola de jovens rurais 25 anos
a gente sabe que aqui na região
muitos jovens vêm despencando embora da
do interior e para nas periferias muitas
vezes e e e quando o jovem começa a
descobrir que ele é jovem da nossa tem
valor porque o jovem da roça nós temos o
nosso dizer que não é só o filho de
tottori mais jovem da roça também têm
valor porque muitas vezes a gente sabe
que o jovem da roça ele tem vergonha de
dizer que é derrota
e pra que isso se eles que são os que
produzem as melhores alimentos então as
sementes crioulas junto com a juventude
esses 25 anos
nós resgatamos quad onde a semente os
jovens somos melhores guardiões a
semente e hoje nós temos na nossa
diocese
nesses dois vale mais do que 500 tipos
de sementes sementes de milho feijão aí
eu trouxe algumas coisa pra dizer esse
feijão aqui é o feijão que se chama
feijão olho de cabra
antigamente eles usava só pra jogar
lotou e essas coisas mas agora descobri
irão esse instituto dos alimentos e em
são paulo descobriu que esse feijão tem
nutriente para nossa pele
nossos cabelo nossas unha e se proteger
também dos dons dos raios solares
então esse feijão aqui a juventude estão
plantando
os quadros estão plantando e é ótimo pra
comer aqui trouxe uma batata que se
chama cara muito diz encarar do ar mas
ela se chama karamu ela porque ela cnema
moela isto pode plantar nas cercas e
teve boa produção e e produzir alimentos
saudáveis para a gente chegar aos 150
anos
aqui tem a marcha também que é muito
gostosa e as sementes de milho têm os
coloridos que vocês também já conhecem
se vocês não conhecem juventude mas
garanto que os os avós de vocês os pais
de vocês conhecem essa semente então o
banco de sementes da solidariedade é pra
dizer não ao agronegócio é pra dizer não
aos venenos e que é possível sim gente
produzir na roça simples na nossa e
produzir alimentos saudáveis
essa coisa de dizer que o que o milho
não está em grande quantidade assim o
que está estragado ea terra que eles
destacaram com os adubos químicos com
veneno então recuperando a terra e isso
a escola de jovens rurais vêm fazendo
com os com os jovens produzindo fazendo
seus composto olhar o potencial da
propriedade
a escola de jovens rurais ela capacita o
jovem diesel multiplicador e de lá no
calo de que ele mora ele consegue criar
um grupo para produzir em primeiro lugar
alimento pra pra família em segundo
lugar pensar junto como venderia onde
vender como fazer perpassa o eixo da
dossa associativismo e cooperativismo é
possível sim na juventude então grito
alto sim é possível
é possível a gente produzir esse infeliz
se contrapor esse aquecimento global que
está aí
tudo isso é eu lia do jornal que fala
muito dos carros e coisas e eu fiquei
pensando
um dia um dos jovens
ele é o projeto dele era plantar
melancia
mas aí ele falou mais e no meu projeto
eu tenho está o caminhão e um caminhão
tem que primeiro ver um pedaço de terra
produzir olhar que tu vai plantar
consorciar não pode plantar por isso que
o agronegócio que planta tudo a mesma
coisa é prejudicar o meio ambiente e e o
jovem foi fazendo e até hoje já faz 15
anos ele casou está muito feliz
casou tá continua estudando tem filhos e
continua produzindo melancia antiga
crioula batatinha crioula milho
todas as da biodiversidade e tem na
propriedade ele é muito feliz que cuida
do meio ambiente e nesse meio tempo nós
também fizemos o be os bio gás
os biodigestores fizemos também as
cisternas na época de seca tem água
patriota então é possível é possível e
parabéns que nós estamos aqui hoje
juntos a juventude que estão estudando
porque nós brasileiros somos o brinco do
mundo por isso que às vezes só sofremos
bastante mas nós somos um povo querido
um povo inteligente o povo que não quer
guerra mas um povo que pode fazer uma
revolução
principalmente na comunicação eu sei que
tem muito jovem
é aqui que estão cursando comunicação
quem é que está cursando comunicação
levanta a mão e os outros mas em qual
curso de todos os cursos tem gente aí
então vocês jovens hoje o planeta está
na mão de vocês
o planeta está na mão da juventude da
roça ea cidade é saber como fazer que o
jovem da roça e o da cidade pode
produzir seus alimentos para chegar na
mesa
deus não quer que as pessoas comem
veneno ea gente sabe pelas pesquisas que
a gente come bastante veneno
o veneno está na mesa quem já assistiu
esses vídeos mas nós tem uma proposta da
escola de jovens rurais
quem tem jovens que conhecem que querem
gostaria de aprender e nós aprender
junto vice-versa aprender junto é de
suma importância
e também nós temos nessa é a juventude
faz os biofertilizantes na propriedade
para usar o potencial que tem isso aqui
é esterco esterco de vaca de boi tem
aqui tempo que diz técnico de cavalos um
leite melado a água e alguns pós de
rocha a cinza e é um biofertilizante que
nem a gente diz que antigamente quando
alguém estava fraco tomar o biotônico
esse aqui é pra cá o biotônico proplan
então isso aqui já é produzido pela
juventude isso é cuidar do meio ambiente
e se cuidar da propriedade que cada
propriedade tanto faz se você mora um
apartamento numa casa na cidade ou lá no
interior o espaço onde você vive é o
espaço do meio ambiente
é ali que dá um giro que a gente não
percebe a nossa mãe
como ela
se vira e isso tudo tem a ver com a lua
tenha bem
e pra isso é pra fazer tem que fazer na
prática os jovens têm lugares onde eles
multiplica semente no grupo 1 cede a
área de terra que a maioria dos jovens
não têm terra então cede a área uma
família sede os jovens tudo vamos fazer
a a semente junto com o observavam
cuidar depois vão fazer então aqui tem
semente feito pelos jovens tanto irritam
feliciano que é na região sul e e os
jovens da região norte que é progresso
então a semente
então a gente tenha em mente é só querer
fazer é só querer se organizar gente
nunca tenha medo e trabalhar com a
juventude a juventude a coisa mais
querida tanto vai se são quilombolas
estão um dia contar uma historinha um
dia cheguei no lugar pra eu falar com
todos os jovens era tudo para nós ser
assentados
era um grupo de 70 jovens e que tinha
quando eu cheguei tinha uma menina
palestrando falando e eu percebi assim
que todos estava no telefone na trocando
idéias sei lá estavam trabalhando na
internet
aí quando chegou minha vez eu disse eu
não vim pra falar muito pra vocês mas
vocês é muito importante e agora com o
telefone é mais importante ainda pra
ajudar a fazer a mudança ajudará a fazer
a mudança
eu falei esse que agora todo mundo pega
as máquinas que vocês têm tantas e
telefone pequenos e grandes e moderno
não é mais uma foto de mim meu apelido
de tiririca quais a foto faz a foto e
inscreva na foto
que as abelhas estão morrendo no mundo e
se as abelhas morrerem no mundo nós
temos quatro anos de vida
nós os humanos com certeza esses prédios
aqui vai passar milano talvez vai
crescer árvores não sei mas a humanidade
está chegando no fim por causa desse
aquecimento global por causa dos maus
tratos da mãe terra terça grande casa
que é nossa
então os jovens como nem todo mundo
gente como abraçar a agroecologia como
produzir ecológico
vamos bater lá vamos conseguir é que os
governos olham para a juventude que
tenha recursos para fazer e ecologia pra
cuidar do meio ambiente e se educar
fazer que todo mundo olha para isso
então a escola de jovens rurais ela é
muito importante a juventude pode também
vim falar com outro jovem trocar idéias
como fazer para ser mais feliz porque
nós já podemos ser felizes que nós temos
tudo no brasil mas nosso brasil pertence
pertence a grande casa o pulmão do do
mundo está no brasil e está sendo
destruído então não podemos deixar fazer
isso mas sim em como investir na
agrícola o dia investir em palestra de
investir nesse sentido
eu acho que é tudo isso está à
disposição de vocês
o banco de sêmen de solidariedade ele
não é meu
ele é de vocês ele é para todos
para o jovem está nossa praça grupos
indígenas os quilombolas pra todos e
todos e todos à reforma agrária com
agroecologia e quem sabe aqui minhas
costas em dizer que nós podemos
junto à terra é meu corpo água meu
sangue
parabéns e muito obrigado
[Aplausos]